it is a difficult decision that many
people will face in their lifetime
finding the right place for an aging
loved one and the search
can be really tough with pandemic
concerns christian costa
spoke to a family on how they found
their perfect home
so you want to be in some place that
really is
a new home to you and feels that way
it's been seven blissful years for
sherry rosenberg
after finding a home for her mother at
oakmont of las vegas
i found this place by actually doing
some research
touring different facilities in the
valley and
we just fell in love with oakmont of las
vegas
safety and care are the top factors
families should search for in a living
facility according to shannon moore with
oakmont
their facility on east flamingo and
pecos just underwent
a major renovation with the renovation
came a brand new beautiful movie theater
which our residents are able to enjoy
every day and watch that sunday football
which is really great
we added a bistro the cost to live here
varies by the needs of the individual
with over 80 staff on property close to
150 rooms
the priority is making each resident
feel at home
senior housing is housing just for 55
and up or for
seniors and senior living is a community
where we provide services so
there are amenities we do provide their
meals their housekeeping but now that we
added our brand new memory care
so they don't necessarily have to leave
when
the time comes of having some kind of
cognitive impairment
it was those amenities and special care
that helped this family
make the right choice the most important
thing is her sense of humor has returned
so she's laughing again and that really
makes me feel good
christian casadas 8 news now oakmont
staff tells us they survived the
pandemic with no positive cases although
they do have a plan in place in case of
an emergency
they say the first step when looking for
a new home is visit the property and be
sure
to do your homework